good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i'm proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2021 2022 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and
sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and
biomedicine where we are enjoying
presentations on friday afternoons from
leading thinkers about the promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences sciences selected participants
in our biomedical data science
innovation lab program will leverage
these presentations as vital material
for our culminating in-person grant
project development workshop to be held
here in historic charlottesville
virginia next june applications for the
biomedical data science innovation lab
program are still being accepted up
until january 31st 2022 so please do
consider applying or encouraging your
junior colleagues to do so we look
forward to reviewing these application
materials
today it is my honor and privilege to
welcome our speaker dr jennifer miller
from yale university school of medicine
dr miller is an assistant professor and
director of the good pharma scorecard a
ranking of pharmaceutical companies on
their bioethics and social
responsibility performance and she is
the founder of the non-profit bio bio
ethics international
prior to joining yale's faculty dr
miller was based at the new york
university school of medicine also at
duke university and at harvard
university she's been a member of the
world economic forum and co-founder of
the new bioethics publication with
scientific american called good medicine
her current work centers on ethics
equity and data sharing in biomedical
research she is a recognized leader in
empirical bioethics and developing and
using metrics to enhance accountability
across the pharmaceutical industry she
also explores the ethics and social
concerns around the use of big data and
ai in medicine and in biomedical
research she has over 80 peer-reviewed
publications including periodic uh
articles appearing in periodicals such
as nature medicine health affairs jama
oncology the uh british medical journal
and tri and uh uh and and has been the
recipients gives me of multiple grants
she's a frequent news commentator and
featured on cbs news wall street journal
and among other places uh in continuing
our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme jennifer's lecture
today is entitled ethics equity and
transparency in biomedical research and
the role of the good pharma scorecard
she's going to draw upon her wealth of
experience in bioethics and
pharmaceutical fields by discussing
transparency and data sharing and in
addition in addition she will cover the
importance of equitable access to the
benefits of biomedical research and what
is more we are super excited to have her
being serving as one of our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab mentors we're super
excited about that as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via youtube and if you're
watching on youtube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2020
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
they have for jennifer by the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i will
personally synthesize these questions
and ask them on your behalf during the
last 10 minutes or so of jennifer's
lecture and with that welcome jennifer
we are so excited to hear from you today
thank you jack for that
overly generous introduction and for the
opportunity to participate in today's
seminar delighted to be here
as jack mentioned i'm an assistant
professor at yale school of medicine and
founder of the nonprofit bioethics
international which i co-founded in 2005
to help advance ethics in healthcare and
healthcare innovation
one of my capstone projects
uh as
my role at yale university and bioethics
international is the good pharma
scorecard
the scorecard is an index designed to
evaluate and rank pharmaceutical
biotech and medical device companies on
their bioethics
and social responsibility performance
annually the process involves
developing bioethics standards and
accountability metrics
uh for companies and then using those
metrics to evaluate and rank companies
year after year to help us do three
things track our progress industry's
progress on bioethics goals over time
catalyze or incent improved behaviors
where needed and recognize and celebrate
where there are best practices
so for today's seminar i'm going to
begin by briefly introducing the good
from a scorecard and show how it
currently works measuring and ranking
companies on their transparency
and data sharing practices by reviewing
the latest 2021 good pharma scorecard
rankings
and then we'll dive into some new
measures that we're developing
and piloting for the scorecard which are
focused on equity in biomedical research
or more specifically
equitable access to the benefits of
clinical research
so let's begin with an introduction the
scorecard is currently focused on the
role of industry in biomedical research
because industry sponsors the vast
majority of clinical research
particularly clinical research
supporting fda approval of our new
medicines by
vaccines and biologics
and devices
we built the scorecard based on a review
of 75 quality improvement strategies
like accreditation certification ratings
and rankings
so you can think of
the u.s news and world report
rankings of best colleges
or
the restaurant grades that you might see
on a restaurant window dependent on its
cleanliness a b and c
and it's also we also built the good
from scorecard based on a review of the
literature which generally shows that
these types of quality improvement
strategies can help improve practices
within companies so on the screen you'll
see one uh study sponsored by
colleagues at harvard and duke which
reviewed 598 firms subject to ratings
and found that low scoring firms
substantially improve practices
when they get a low score
supporting the old adage
what gets measured
gets done
so the scorecard is designed to
comprehensively address
the key bioethics concerns
about
the pharmaceutical medical device and
biotech sectors however
we have only publicly debuted so far our
rankings on transparency and data
sharing practices
and we decided to prioritize
transparency as our initial uh starting
place because in the first place there
was robust evidence
uh suggesting a potential widespread
transcen transparency problem in
clinical research so on the screen you
see one example of a study
conducted by monique anderson and rob
kaliff who were both at duke at the time
uh published in new england journal of
medicine showing that 20
of registered clinical trials had
reported results
in clinical trials like of the nih
registry within one year of their
completion and even if you looked at
five years after the completion you
still could only find about 50 of trials
having
public results
in the registry
so along with evidence of a potential
problem we also recognize the importance
of clinical trial
transparency for quality patient care
it's hard to practice evidence-based
medicine if you have incomplete or
biased
data
also it is important for innovation as
scientists benefit from building upon
the knowledge
and research of other scientists and
honoring and protecting
research participants
we don't often think about you know why
are we justified in allowing medical
experimentation on people on humans and
one of the reason is its potential to
contribute to generalizable knowledge
that can help people
which is hard to accomplish when or if
results and data remain behind locked
doors
and further
transparency is important for trust
and we're focused on trustworthiness and
appropriate trust in a sector a recent
study by pew or a survey found that 57
of adults say they
trust scientific research findings more
if the researchers made
their data publicly available
and as we're seeing right now and know
from the study from the literature
distrust
can result in disengagement from a
system and in this case hesitancy to use
products like vaccines we're seeing this
with covid19 vaccines right now
so the good from a scorecard 2021
rankings we have five years of rankings
and i'll just uh
present your the most recent findings
uh the 2021 rankings which came out in
july or the summer of 2021 this year
focused on companies with a novel drug
or biologic like a vaccine approved by
the fda in 2016
and 2017
and so here's what that sample
characteristics looked like
we ranked and evaluated 42 different
companies 17 large companies and 25
non-large
that sponsored a total of 62 products 40
drugs and 22 biologics which were
approved based on a thousand over a
thousand clinical trials
so to score companies on their
transparency and data sharing we first
assess them on the trial level
and then pool trials to get to a company
score so we look at three sets of trials
in a new drug application or biologics
licensed application basically a company
submits an application to the fda for a
product approval much like a university
student might submit a college
application to a university for
admission
a company
can do this to the fda for product
approval in that application
uh all of the trials clinical trials
that the company conducted on the
experiment
will be listed in there and so what we
do is we go through every fda approval
package to find all of the clinical
trials that a company
conducted
and figure out the percentage of those
public results and we look at three
samples of those trials first the all
trial sample which is just what it
sounds like whether all you know the
percentage of all those trials with
public results than just the trials
conducted in patients basically
excluding trials and healthy volunteers
and then third just trials subject to
legal reporting requirements under u.s
laws
i'll dive more into this in a second
so i'm not going to go through every
product finding because now the ratings
include a lot of um
products but we'll we'll go through sort
of the aggregate findings of what we
found from this year's rankings
per
product so per drug or biologic a median
of 62 percent of the trials conducted
for fda approval are publicly available
so 38 are publicly unavailable
on the product level
only 26
of our reviewed fda approved products
were fully transparent meaning they had
summary results
in a clinical trial registry or in a
publication within six months of fda
approval of
the product
if you narrow the sample from all trials
to just trials conducted in patients for
the approved indication
per product you'll find that 100
a median of 100 of trials in patients
per product are available but if you
look
if you step back and look at the product
level still you're only getting about
two-thirds of products
with public results for their trials
within six months of fda approval of a
product so two-thirds of products
are fully transparent about the results
of their patient trials and one-third
even for patient trials are missing
um results
if you narrow the sample even further to
just those trials subject to mandatory
results reporting under the law
you'll still find 58 percent of products
failing to meet baseline us legal
requirements
for clinical trial transparency
to put these into context a bit more
per product there's a median of 13
clinical trials in an application
about five of those are in patients for
the approved indications would be in the
in the patient trial sample and then
about three of those would be subject to
mandatory
uh legal disclosures
mandatory results reporting under the
law
so that's the product level so now let's
look at let's aggregate up to the
company level
so the company score
does not include that all trials review
it
includes the patient trials score
and the legal compliance score and then
we add a data sharing score so not just
looking at whether results summary
results are reported in a clinical trial
registry or in a paper but actually
looking if the company commits to
sharing patient level data
from a study
and here
i want to mention that we also give
companies a 30-day amendment window so
we give companies their scores and we
give them 30 days to improve things uh
and about half of low scoring companies
have traditionally taken us up on that
offer you can see all these green lines
and improve their practices within 30
days of getting a low score
so here's what the 2021 company rankings
look like
you'll see that about 58
of companies
were fully transparent of all about all
the trials they conducted in patients
for the approved indication for their
products
42 percent of companies
met um
minimum legal requirements for results
reporting
and 26 met the data sharing
measures overall
17 of companies or 7 out of the 42 that
we reviewed
fully met all of our transparency
measures
so in an effort to
create a race to the top we emphasize a
leaderboard
companies that score in the top 10
and also
perfect score 100 on our measures this
shows that not only are these measures
possible they're reasonable and it
highlights best practices
so these are the companies that scored
on the leaderboard this year
and we also do a deep dive factor
analysis to try and understand the root
causes of
good and bad transparency performance
and here what you can see is looking at
the
association of company size company
location and product type
with transparency performance
what you can see is company size is
driving
transparency scores and in this case
non-large companies smaller companies
are
less likely to comply
with laws u.s laws requiring results
reporting here you see that
the median score for large companies is
100 and non-large it's only 57
and then uh smaller companies are less
likely to have data sharing policies and
data sharing policies that meet our
measures so large companies the score is
100 on data sharing in contrast to
smaller companies
we have only 20
so it's really
the small company the large companies
are starting to perform better and
better and the small companies who are
new to the scorecard this year but
they're they're added to the scorecards
the first time this year still have a
lot of room for improvement
um
so we as i mentioned we've been doing
this with five years worth of data and
the good news is that we see there's
some evidence suggesting impact from the
scorecard
in the first place the 2019 good firma
scorecard rankings published in bmj
show that half of low scoring large
companies improved their practices and
procedures within 30 days
of receiving a low good pharma scorecard
a low good from a scorecard score
further the
industry company median scores are going
up year after year
even though we're actually shortening
the time frame for results reporting
further
um the scorecard is becoming
institutionalized within the sector as
companies
when they score well are using it in
their
corporate social responsibility and
human rights due diligence annual
reports
and social media outreach
um so the more attention and more
eyeballs on the scorecard the more
incentive
there is for other companies to improve
practices the better lever for change it
becomes
um we're also have partnered with
scientific american
to launch a new publication called good
medicine
which goes out to which reaches eight to
nine million people
annually so our first this is what the
first publication looked like
and we have worked with ernst young
in the past to sponsor our award
ceremony every year and so here you see
the companies who scored
in the top five the first few years
getting their actual transparency awards
so based on
this
evidence suggesting a potential impact
or a likely impact we've decided we'd
like to do more and the next
uh topic we're going to address is
equity in biomedicine
so in particular when we think about
equity or equitable access to research
benefits we're just looking at two
things so far
first is
demographic representation or fair
inclusion in clinical research and i'll
explain what these terms mean in a
second and the second second one is fair
access to medicines and vaccines among
low and middle-income countries
who help us develop our medicines and
vaccines by hosting clinical trials so
let's look at the first
issue
many studies have shown that new
medicines and vaccines
tend to be tested on populations who are
younger
and healthier and more likely to
identify as whites than real world
patients in u.s u.s clinical
settings with studied conditions
so here you just see one study
conducted by lorae and colleagues
which is showing that patients
identifying as black and hispanic
patients
as black or hispanic are
underrepresented in cancer trials in
proportion to the disease burden
measured by incidence and mortality
these
under representation
in research is concerning for several
reasons
in the
one key one is it can leave doctors
payers and patients in a quandary
about how to apply trial findings
to themselves or their clinical
practices
when
they or their patients do not represent
the racial identity ethnicity age sex or
gender of trial participants
excluding
certain groups from research
can exclude them from having treatments
guided by evidence that applies to
patients like them
which can potentially lead to harm
exposure and lost opportunities to
pursue more effective therapies
the literature has highlighted this
problem and suggested some processes for
improving it
like conducting more decentralized or
community hospital-based trials
offering transportation and child care
for participants
broadening trial eligibility criteria
and there have been several
highly
high-profile efforts policy efforts to
diversify clinical trial participants
but all of this has had limited impact
disparities persist
and
here you can see a recent editorial from
the editors of new england journal of
medicine
calling for
a discussion about what it means to have
acceptable and reasonable representation
in clinical research and you also see
here a study from jama network open
saying we need diversity enrollment
targets
for research because we currently don't
have them
so we so
when you look at the literature there
are two main ways for assessing
demographic representation in clinical
research or fair inclusion
one way is to compare
the demographics of participants
enrolled in a trial to the demographics
of the u.s population
the other way is a method developed by
dr rita poon who at the time was at the
fda
published in 2013
which involves constructing a
participation to prevalence ratio or ppr
which you can do by dividing the percent
of a particular population in a among
study participants by the percent of
that particular population in the real
world disease population so for example
if we wanted to look at women we would
compare
the percent of women participating in a
trial
to the proportion in the disease
population
it's a pretty basic equation
we
our team in a study led by a brilliant
yale medical student tanvi varma
used poon's method to assess demographic
representation
for novel cancer drugs approved by the
fda
between 2012 and 2016. it was about 45
cancer therapeutics
and the first thing to note is that
we found
transparency
problems
um
a lot of the demographic data were not
transparent for products and trials
only 48 of pre-market
studies meaning trials conducted before
approval had publicly available
ethnicity data
77 had age data
and 81 had race data sex is actually
very consistently reported and in the
post marketing studies these numbers go
down
only 30 of post-marketing studies have
publicly available ethnicity data 48
race 64 age and 75 sex
for the trials that we were able to find
the demographic composition
we then looked at representation
while we found that women were generally
adequately represented in pre and
post-marketing studies
older adults and patients identifying as
black
were under-represented in both pre and
post-marketing studies
so now our team is working on
building a company ranking informed by
poon's ppr methods
to
set fair inclusion targets
for companies and use those to benchmark
their performance track our progress and
recognize where there are best practices
so half we anticipate half the score
looking at the transparency of
demographic data and the other half
to actually look at
the composition the demographic
representation of a trial
and we'll put those scores together to
come up with a fair inclusion
score
along with considering
who we should enroll in research
i'm also interested
in what we might owe
populations participating in research
starting with national populations
many studies have shown that clinical
research supporting u.s medicine
and vaccine approvals has been
globalized and is largely conducted in
other countries increasingly
lower income countries
here you see just one study focused on
heart failure trail trials which found
participant enrollment from north
america decreased from 43
from 2001 to 2004 to 27 between 2013
to 2014.
and to my knowledge the rate at which
market access to products
is obtained by the countries hosting
these trials
supporting fda product approvals had not
been studied and so i sought to design a
study to answer three questions first
where are our novel drugs and biologics
being tested
secondly how commonly and quickly are
these medicines
approved for marketing in the countries
where they are tested
and three are there any differences
occurring in these approvals by country
income and geographic or geographic
regions
before i go over the results i want to
say that
marketing access meaning whether a
country approves a product first for
marketing
does not guarantee a patient can afford
a product or vaccine or that there is a
reasonable supply but is generally a
critical precondition for those later
important stage access issues so this is
why we started with
marketing approval to begin with so this
sample looked at fda approved drugs in
2012 and 2014 sponsored by large
companies
large companies were defined as the 20
largest by market cap
so our sample looked at in the fda
approved a total of 79 novel drugs in
2012 and 2014
34 of which or 43
were sponsored by large pharmaceutical
companies
approved based on a total of 898 trials
63 of which had publicly available trial
locations
and these products targeted
a total of 28 unique cancer
indications
63
of trials
had trial location data and the rest did
not
and we found that each drug was
manufactured was tested in a median of
25 different countries
in addition to the united states
including a median of 20 high income
countries six upper middle income
countries a meeting of one low middle
income country and a median of low zero
low income countries
only one drug in our sample was tested
in a low income country
and that was sorturo a tb related
treatment was tested in kenya but 17
drugs were tested in south africa
so within one year of fda approval only
three percent of the drugs in our sample
were approved for marketing in all the
countries where they were tested if you
look at five years later you still only
find about 15 of these drugs
approved for marketing where they were
tested
on the country level there were 70
countries that contributed research
participants for these fda approvals and
what we found is that
seven percent of these countries got
market access to those drugs within one
year of fda approval and even if you
look at five years you're still only
finding about 31 of countries
with marketing approval and these
numbers don't change substantially
if you bump it out to seven years
30
of countries
stratifying market access by country
income level which is what you see on
the screen now
we found that 13 of high income
countries got market access to products
within one year compared to zero upper
middle and zero lower middle
looking at five years out
you see that forty six percent of high
income countries got access nine percent
of upper middle and twenty two percent
of lower middle income countries at five
years
breaking these findings out by
geographical region
market access was lowest in african
countries followed by the middle east
middle eastern countries and access was
highest unsurprisingly in canada and
eastern europe
at five years followed by western
european countries and oceana
latin american countries and asian
countries fell towards the middle of the
pack
as i mentioned at the beginning
marketing access doesn't guarantee that
there are enough doses or that a product
is affordable
so our team
conducted another study led by reshma
ramachandra at yale
a fellow at yale
examining
market access to covid19 vaccines in the
countries where they were tested so we
focused on the world health organization
um vaccines recommended for use
and we found that they were for
completed trials they were tested in
also a total of 25 countries as of
september 7th 2021
and we found that among the 11 high
income countries hosting completing
trials completed trials 91 authorized
the tested vaccine and received enough
doses to vaccinate a median of 51 52 of
their populations age 15 and older
however you looked at lower and middle
lower middle and upper middle income
countries
the rates of authorization were high 100
and 91 respectively
however the median vaccination rates
were much lower they were 31 and 15
of their populations respectively
and if you look at
including ongoing and completing trials
the corresponding rates go up for high
income countries and they go down for
all other income
level countries all other income groups
and this is a study that we didn't
conduct this um
was done by
noria humades
and
that research group looked at drugs
approved by the fda in 2011 and 2012 to
see if they were registered and
commercialized but they also looked at
affordability
in latin american countries where they
were tested
and what they found is that
30 they looked at 33 products and they
expected to see them registered in 114
different places and they found that
only 60 were registered
where they were tested
and that with
only one exception
all of the products cost more than the
monthly minimum wage in all those
countries and 12 products cost at least
five times the monthly minimum wage in
the country
concluding that most many pharmaceutical
products tested in latin america are
unavailable and or unaffordable to most
of the populations
so from an ethics perspective ethicists
tend to agree that communities providing
trial participants should stand to
benefit from their participation
and you can find this principle in the
declaration of helsinki
and the cioms guidelines for
international clinical research
a corollary of this principle is that to
avoid
exploitation research should not
ordinarily be conducted in a national
population that does not stand to
benefit from the knowledge to be gained
or the interventions to be developed and
that language is taken from the helsinki
declaration
since this clearly is not consistently
happening we are now building measures
for the good pharma scorecard to start
tracking our progress and incenting
change in this area where needed
so wrapping up the good pharma scorecard
is to is designed to address the key
bioethics challenges around biomedical
innovation focusing on clinical trials
sponsored by industry
and so far we've launched the scorecard
to address clinical trial transparency
and data sharing practices and this year
we'll be debuting our new equity
measures
and rankings for biomedical research
there's evidence suggesting that the
good firm scorecard is having an
impact with scores going up
on the measures that we add to the
scorecard and 50 of large scoring
companies improving procedures within 30
days of getting a low score for the 2019
rankings
socially responsible
indices and environmental social
governance esg funds and investors are
beginning to use and look at the
rankings
and the software that large companies
use to
check their own transparency is building
some of our measures into their software
to automate
a company's
use of the scorecard or evaluation of
how they might score
so we hope to continue to have a
beneficial impact for patients
and continue to develop measures and
pilot them so now i look forward to
hearing everybody's questions and
comments
jennifer thank you so much what an
intriguing idea coming up with the good
pharma score it kind of reminds me of a
of a zagat score or a michelin stars or
you know and of course uh many of us who
are at universities or
a lot of our universities seem to pay uh
a
possibly undue amount of attention to
their u.s news rankings um it's
interesting because each one of those
different ranking systems takes on kind
of a different approach i think that the
zagat score or at least it used to
depend upon you know the rate the
rankings available from
um like diners going to restaurants for
example so it'd be basically be you know
crowdsourced whereas the michelin scores
for example are you know expert
restaurant diners would go and evaluate
them so it's kind of a couple different
models and then i think even us news um
has a kind of different number and
variety of things that they rank
relative to another
um university ranking system like the
times of london university ones
are you aware of any other systems that
attempt to do this and do they have a
different approach than yours or are you
the only game in town at the moment
right well if there were other groups
doing this i probably wouldn't have
started
so um
so the short answer is uh from a
bioethics perspective no however there
is one other ranking
system related and complementary to our
work but not duplicative and it's the
access to medicines index
um
which was i think at one point actually
funded by the gates foundation
and atmi
looks at
the accessibility of products in low and
middle-income countries
um but it doesn't overlap at all with
our work
that's nice so you have you have your
own niche then
right for better or worse uh yes if
you're interested in the social
responsibility performance and bioethics
of the pharmaceutical sector you're
stuck with the good pharma scorecard i
think that that's just fine you know
what does the fda uh have in terms of
its expectations for companies it seems
like a lot of the work that you've drawn
from obviously is the data that you're
mining here comes from fda approved
clinical trials does the fda have any
standards or anything against which
people are supposed to adhere to or is
that sort of
loosey-goosey i guess so there is it's a
good question so
embedded in your question is a larger
a larger question which is um you know
what kind of ethical responsibilities do
we want to ask of companies from a
minimal
minimal
um
ass we'd want them to to
to comply with u.s laws
and so
although i would you know argue that
ethics is
clearly not synonymous with legal
compliance but
um there is a law if you're thinking
about transparency and data sharing in
the u.s that requires companies to
report summary results of trials
they conduct non-phase one trials
conducted in patients in the u.s or by
u.s sponsor
and what i tried to show in my initial
slides was how narrow that law was right
so
if it's a large company a large company
sponsors 25 different experiments for
fda approval of their product if you
look at all companies it's about 13
trials per product and the law covers a
median of three of those
um and some products are approved based
on zero trials that are subject to
mandatory disclose disclosures under the
law but notwithstanding the narrowness
or arguable narrowness of the law
uh
a substantial amount of companies fail
to meet baseline legal requirements
um so
to answer your the long that's a long
answer to say there are um laws right
that the things that the fda could
require
um
however they're they're they're not
being followed and uh
the fda the government could impose uh
penalties for non-compliance which it
has yet to do
is that
is that is that politically motivated do
you feel or financially motivated that
the fda hasn't imposed penalties on some
of these companies well i would so i'm
empirical based i would suggest a
qualitative study of fda employees to
find out what happened um but
one hunch is that when the law was
originally uh
uh
in 2007. in my opinion the language was
uh opaque and it wasn't
so i think there was some exploitation
of the ambiguities in the law
um and perhaps that
caused some challenges in applying it
and um
so you know let's hope that the fda
there are there are a lot of reasons
i'm not going to comment on those uh but
let's hope that the fda starts better
monitoring and enforcing this law it's
just started issuing non-compliance
letters to companies for the first time
but it's really only gone out to a
handful of companies
in comparison to how many should receive
such letters and like i said i don't
believe to this date any civil penalties
have been collected
any um monetary penalties okay do you
work with any um legal scholars um who
can kind of help provide guidance and
insight on you know kind of what
is allowable or what uh kind of the
range of things that exist within those
laws does that make sense yeah sure well
fidel has been was clarified in 2017 so
there's not as much of a range of
allowable sort of interpretations
um but yeah on those papers you'll see a
couple legal scholars michelle mello is
in this
law school at stanford but actually kind
of goes the reverse way we're often
since we're working with legal scholars
sometimes we know more because when you
start to apply and measure
uh compliance it raises more questions
than if you just look at the language so
we work together on interpreting the law
do you um
you also mentioned that uh the good
pharma score can be applied to medical
devices as well and i think the examples
you gave were largely pharmaceutical
companies um do you are you working with
any um or rather working with any data
from medical device companies as they're
kind of you know prototyping or uh
attempting to uh get data on the
efficacy of a particular medical device
at all
yes thank you so much for asking so this
year
we are adding medical devices for the
first time so we looked at all of the
um
original or novel
medical devices that the fda approved in
2017 and benchmark them using the same
methods um so you'll have to stay tuned
for a couple more months
before those findings come out but it
adds a substantial number of companies
and products to our reviews and every
year going forward you'll now see drugs
biologics and medical devices
every year we expand the scorecard
incrementally
and this year was the addition of
biologics and devices
that's great and all size companies
what and you again have focused it looks
like you've you know most most of most
of your data comes from fda related um
activities are you looking at companies
from other countries for example great
britain or the european union or
elsewhere
where
pharmaceutical
scores would also be helpful
the company doesn't have to be
based in the u.s to get ranked they just
have to submit a product for fda
approval
um and we it turns out that the location
of a country actually doesn't correlate
with
a change in transparency practice or
score
um it's really the size of company that
was that uh trying to find that slide
so
products submitted to f to the fda for
approval are not um entirely based in
the us they're global and research is
globalized so
by nature the studies
are all global yeah i guess i i meant
the um
uh like the european for example or the
british equivalent of the food and drug
administration can you mine any um
information that they have that's
publicly available because there may be
companies that apply for a approval in
one country that don't send something
into the food and drug administration
ema approval perhaps the european
medicines association yeah so there's
usually a
strong relation between say
the canadian
the european and the u.s
drug agency
but but so you wouldn't necessarily have
to use the ema data or canadian or
sort of a developed country but what
would be interesting and what we're not
doing is looking at um
um
not initial novel drugs but um
generics
right so because they are often you know
more um
they may not all make it to the u.s
market so because we're only looking at
novel products um it makes sense for us
to focus on
uh fda ema and um
you know canadian uh approved drugs i
see that makes sense now it's
interesting because you were talking
about uh i was writing down a question
myself about this um at this at the very
minute you brought up your slide and
kind of answered it for me
was um what is the score that p that a
company gets um related to the size of
that company so i saw like you know
amgen was i think number two on the list
and there's a few other major
pharmaceutical companies and as you move
down the list they tended to get smaller
so there appeared to be a relationship
there that you answered and i was also
kind of curious about like
whether the scores related to their
stock price or you know some other
profit margin related index and i was
just curious if because i presume the
size of the company and their stock
prices correlated so i wouldn't be
surprised if the score was also
correlated with their you know some
financial element of that particular
company do you find that you track that
kind of information too
um do you want can you expand on that
your sense is if there's a dip in the
price that you'd see a different score
for example i presume that if if stock
price is you know varies linearly with
their score uh was just kind of curious
if that's something you see evidence of
yeah we're looking at that right now um
stay tuned
you okay i mean i i i have to say the
this the scorecard i my senses and i
have a hunch but we need to
really measure measure the alpha
is um
it's a it's a good predictor of
potential future problems like we saw
valiant
tank in the
scorecard um
you know before
the scandals broke out about it um
buying uh supposedly undervalued drugs
and marking them up a mean of 200
percent right the
scandalous business model um valiant is
no more i think it's bausch and lohmer
bausch and health and
google the right name
so my hunch is there is
a correlation between
transparency performance
possibly also ethics in general and um
you know other factors but we need to do
a deep dive in that sure
um so when you are in in your own
uh
kind of work here um what effort do you
make to make the data that you're
gathering and the analyses and uh their
interpretation open and transparent and
accessible
for anyone who wants to dig through this
data
which i encourage you to do and if you
know make use of it it's on triad it's a
non-profit repository and we put all of
our raw data
sheets on dryad every year
and they actually are used a lot um
heavily downloaded i think mostly by
lawyers
double checking
our work i know one time an industry
trade association sort of hired a
communications firm to redo all of our
analyses didn't find much differences
but something i should mention is that
we send all of our data
to the companies for
validation so they get all of their raw
data sheets and they have an opportunity
to correct anything
that they think might need
correcting and if we can verify what
they say through public sources like
other fda documents or other regulatory
body documents um we will make
corrections and
sometimes i would say not infrequently
there are typos in the fda documents um
so that validation process can be
helpful
that's great um what role
could there be for people doing
data science and ai related work uh
as two different elements of this um on
something like this to help kind of
expand the dimensionality and the the
nuance that goes into the good pharma
score
i would love to hear from you know you
guys what ethical challenges you're
encountering or things you'd like to see
done better
for sure if you're doing data science
and um
using ai to analyze uh data there's not
a lot of transparency in that space
right the algorithms used are often
opaque
um sometimes because they're proprietary
yeah and so i think it's really
important that we start to talk about
what transparency means
in those data sets and for those
algorithms also that we think about the
same things i just presented right the
are there biases in the data
um you know who are who's represented in
the data we know genomic data for
example tends to be overwhelmingly
um
uh caucasian and uh you know from
certain countries global south being
underrepresented
and then when uh you know it's the exact
same challenges we're seeing here when
um non-high-income countries
or the global south are included in data
sources you know what are they getting
in return for that
um just like we said here we tend to
test drought if we test drugs in
low-income countries we're not even
making them available on the market let
alone
affordable or insufficient supply so we
definitely don't want to repeat
uh these mistakes in the newer emerging
space of ai and
big data so i think now is really a good
time to start thinking through that and
trying to set a chart a course forward
in a good
a good way and a good path
are have you communicated with um
lawmakers senators congressmen um and
others who may be influential in helping
to
craft new laws or tidy up pro existing
laws that
may
kind of encourage pharmaceutical
companies to not be as transparent
there is a group at yale called crit the
collaboration for research integrity and
transparency
that is full of a powerhouse of lawyers
and they have used these findings and
the findings of others to submit
you know to work on the advocacy on the
policy level uh with some success um so
this work supports their work but i am
not an advocate right i am a sort of a
researcher
um
so certainly partner with groups like
crit um but if you're you know if you're
looking for
lobbyists and advocates i'd look more
towards them not lobbyists but advocates
for um policy change
does that um
do the
does the score and the sub scales that
you're
measuring one do you see that growing
over say the next five years in terms of
the number of i mean it seems like you
are the number of different dimensions
are there any other dimensions that um
you know are
maybe ones that you're considering but
haven't quite fully fleshed out yet
where um they may be
areas of further growth over the next
say five years or so
yeah so the idea of the scorecard is to
be comprehensive and look at all of the
bioethics and social responsibility
concerns we have about companies
particularly those that are important to
get right for patient health for our
health
all around the world
so
after clinical trial transparency and
data sharing and adding the medical
devices we're going to target equity in
biomedical research looking at those two
issues to begin with
who's included in research right fair
inclusion and
representation of groups beginning with
sex gender age
race and ethnicity
and then not only looking at who's
included
but then what are they getting
in um
exchange for participating and on that
we'll look on the national level
which countries are participating in
clinical research and helping us develop
drugs and vaccines and seeing what
they're getting in exchange for
participation starting very humbly with
looking at whether they get market
access
and then ideally um
expanding also into
um
looking at the affordability and
availability of products so including
drug pricing akin to that study that i
presented in about south american
countries or latin american countries
um that will keep us busy for i would
suspect you know a good amount of month
um
we can go faster the more funding we
have which we're working on
uh and then after that
we'll have to you know step back and see
uh what's going on but again the the end
goal is to have a comprehensive
bioethics and social responsibility
index um i am exploring partnering with
a couple groups to add in the
environmental impact of pharma
to create a more comprehensive esg
um index and it's remarkable that we
just don't have an esg
index focused on pharma so
within five years the dream or the ideal
goal is to have a comprehensive esg
set of measures and rankings um that are
used by investors and anyone with you
know any kind of lever to
really catalyze or continue the change
that we need to see in the sector
given its important role in all of our
health and i think that the cova 19
pandemic has highlighted how important
it is to get things right with this
sector in terms of
the way it develops drugs and vaccines
and the way they ultimately become
accessible and reachable for all of us
well jennifer that on that note it's a
great place to kind of stop you've given
us so much to think about and kind of
think about the the social
responsibility the ethical
responsibility of major pharmaceutical
companies and how we might rank them and
kind of sort them hopefully encourage
those that are not doing such a good job
about ways at which they might approve
and how we might um help to develop best
practice standards based upon these
different target areas that you you're
focusing on i look forward to seeing how
this develops over the next five to ten
years or so thank you so much for
sharing your work with us and thank you
everybody for for joining us today um we
really appreciate it and uh we wish you
all a good friday and a very good
weekend and we'll see you next week
thanks again jennifer thanks